[Music]
when i talk to marco bizarri i just have
this amazing sense of joy
even his name marco bizarri sparks joy
but who knew that joy could actually be
a leadership principle
it is joy and humility that marco has
brought to gucci
as the new ceo and he's completely
transformed that company
it's humanity and finding joy in little
things
that has been his secret this
is a bit of optimism
thank you so much for doing this it's
such a pleasure to see you i have to say
it's a pleasure for me you know we've
only had the chance to interact a few
times but i have to say
every time i've walked away inspired
you're well known obviously in the
fashion world because most of your
career has been in the fashion world
but to me you're one of those ceos
honestly that deserves to be celebrated
everywhere you're one of those few ceos
that with all of the pressures upon you
to make all your short-term financial
numbers like
so many others you're so committed to
people
and when you came into gucci you came in
to a culture
of fear and turned it into this culture
of
inspiration and empowerment
please tell me how you did it i am so
fascinated by this story
you know i mean i was lucky in a way
because i mean i was part of the group
already because i started working in
caring like 15 years ago already so i
knew
what was happening in gucci it was
famous for this kind of a culture of you
know fear authority etc but it's
not what i am and i really believe that
you cannot pretend to be someone else so
it's like when you do an interview right
but you try to
think what they expect from you and so
you try to pretend to be a different
person
you can also make it the problem is that
it's not gonna lie when you're gonna be
hired so at the very end you're gonna be
fired
so it's better to be yourself from the
beginning always being i mean
very optimistic you know very believing
in people etc etc and also
first and foremost i really believe that
creativity especially for fashion right
i think
overall cannot be fostered in a ambience
of you know fear
let me push back there a little bit yeah
yeah because
your industry is big egos this is like a
lot of
creative personality driven industries
it could you know could be a chef in
a famous restaurant it's big egos that
do operate out of fear
and they do have success some of these
brands were built
with these fear environments absolutely
absolutely absolutely i think times
have changed as well and since since the
70s i believe that that was the norm
they think that they can be creative
people and doing amazing collection
because like they're blessed from gods
in a way right because i mean the only
ones that can do these kinds of things
in reality you have teams that are
amazing below them
and these people most of the time they
are very very good i assure that we're
incredible like
you know creative people i mean creative
directors going to work like 10 p.m and
working until four in the morning
asking the team to be present or asking
meetings at 9 00 a.m and then
in reality um showing up like in the
afternoon
so all these kind of things maybe some
some more subtle so
something more evident like this one but
something that i i don't believe
is fair first and foremost because i
mean there's no respect for people
and i've been told by my parents from
the beginning to keep respect from
people that is going to pay off yeah so
this is the way which i wanted to to
live my life
always this is amazing to me by the way
that people actually got away with this
that you said they they wanted to go to
work at 10 p.m and stay till 4am and
they made the team come in
or call these meetings for the morning
and don't show up till the afternoon
like how do people even get away with
this
maybe in this case you just want to keep
your job you feel that there's no other
life
than the one that you are living that
you are like in
in a bubble so it's just well to be part
of a different situation where i go to
work with a smile
that doesn't mean that i'm i'm not
asking for results it's completely the
reverse
i mean especially fashion company to
have someone that
is exactly like you feels like you
because otherwise it doesn't work
meaning you need a partner who shares
your philosophy of people first
exactly right same values exactly and i
so appreciate that you believe in this
idea of partnership that it's kind of
like what you just said before these
creative egos that come in you know with
a gift from god
but even at the ceo level that it's not
one person either it has to be a
partnership
absolutely these are so different you
know capabilities
i mean i would never be able to design a
dress so i need to rely on someone else
and normally these people they don't
have a clue about the processes and
finance is such a combination that means
to to work together
otherwise there's no way in which
company can be successful
or you can be successful it's not gonna
last right right
so tell me some of the specific things
that you did
to change the culture because i think
that's the thing that i find
particularly interesting that you did
some
very simple but very powerful things the
very very very first day when i joined
the company
i was used to going to the corridors of
gucci as a partner of
from coming from other brands and all of
what i
i was you know watching in the corridors
in the meeting rooms or
everywhere boating design and in
business
offices there were all these pictures
of all these celebrities of the 60s and
the 70s all in black and white
and i was thinking to myself but there's
no joy
i mean it's all legacy and no future
and considering the transition that we
were living in our water that i was 2015
and i really thought that the world was
going into the direction was completely
different from the past sure
i said to myself what should i do to
tell the people
in gucci that we are going to move to
the future
respecting the past but not rather in
the past
so and that's to say i should ask all
the people across the board in all
offices worldwide we have
500 shops and many buildings in all the
regions
of geographical region of the world okay
the very first day at nine o'clock
italian time when i enter for the first
time in gucci they
take out all the pictures of all these
people
everywhere without telling anybody that
what we were doing
you can imagine the kind of impact that
this guy is crazy
he doesn't respect our past what he
thinks is gonna be
or what he's gonna do et cetera et
cetera but the fact is
i was not going against the pastor gucci
that actually
is the strength of the brand but the way
which you use it needs to be
to talk to people that are relevant
today if you want to keep this
these things are they are you need to
change continuously yeah because i mean
if you want to keep your leadership
you cannot think that if you stay as you
are you're going to keep your leadership
you need to continue to change if you've
all maintained the leadership
so it's a continuous change that you
need to instill in the company and to
create continuous change you need to
create a
an ambiance where people are willing to
take a risk
that are not killed if they make a
mistake and that is the most difficult
thing because that foster creativity for
sure
but on the other side you need to make
sure that the company can continue to go
in the direction that
it makes sense and we with the company
like out that we have 20 000 people
today
i mean this is the most difficult thing
that you need to to fight every single
day in order to make sure that the
people are
free to express themselves so you took
all the old black and white pictures of
the past with these
mostly dead celebrities on the wall a
company that
mistook legacy for a museum you're like
you know you
it's good to have a legacy but you don't
want to put it in a museum put it all in
formaldehyde and you can't grow
so what did you have put up on the walls
instead
for one year everything remained the
same so white corridors
oh so you had nothing on the walls for a
year zero no because we wanted to
restart this we wanted to restart
the story and you know in fashion yeah
to restart the story it takes at least
12 18 months because from the moment in
which alexander did the first show to
the moment in which we have the
product in the shops uh it takes like
seven eight months but then we started
not to cover all the shop with the
products of alexander because i mean
we didn't really know if that was
successful so we decided
to take a risk but to take a risk on
like 35 percent of the shops
40 percent of the shops and we kept the
owners and eyes and the others in order
to see
what was the the feedback of the
consumers because the point is that
when you want to change so dramatically
the static
you don't know you cannot do focus
groups because at the beginning
everybody was not happy about the
collection of alexander because i mean
there was such a shift
people were a little bit disconnected so
we we fed that was the right choice to
do
we felt that was going to to have a good
deal but i must say that
the most creative people in the industry
i could say about anna wintour or
business or fashion or wwd the people
managing
they saw immediately the talent of
alessandro they were the ones
that praised the new aesthetic of
alessandro gucci
the consumers they were more reluctant
to accept this
so this is really interesting in the
sort of outside the fashion world
everybody's obsessed with focus groups
you would never take that financial risk
to completely
throw out the old put in the new and
then
just cross your fingers and hope it goes
and you said we just had to trust our
feeling yeah exactly
that takes a tremendous amount of
courage you know this kind of chorus
comes as well when when you have a
situation where you
you can really see that the business is
not going well the beauty of changing
when
things goes well is the best because i
mean you can
you know you make a mistake you you
don't really care because i mean you're
going to be offset by the rest of the
companies going
in with many projects in the right
direction but the business of which at
that time was going down quite
dramatically in the sense that every
single day
we were at minus 30 minus 35 percent i
was
clearly seeing that the business was
going down and when you fashion
you lose appeal it's like you go down
from a mountain
very very quick so there was not even a
choice
so and and and you cannot do in in this
dramatically changed dramatical change
you cannot do focus groups
you're talking about alessandro michele
the creative director of gucci
yeah for something that's about profound
turnaround pivoting
a reinvention you have to have some sort
of
guiding principle some vision something
or other and that's the thing you're
trusting in that's the that's the gut
thing
yes how did you resist the pressure i
mean there were massive pressures
internally
you weren't popular when you showed up
what i did
especially at the beginning maybe that
goes a little bit against what you are
teaching but now i do exactly what
you're teaching
so so that's fine at the beginning
because i needed to make a change very
very quick i told to all my people
especially to my direct reports
that was not a democracy in the sense
that i took the responsibility of the
change
you are not going to be responsible you
just follow don't question
because i mean in this kind of changes
if you start asking you start
compromising then you i mean
the message that is going to come at the
end is going to be too deducted so i
didn't want that
and then i started traveling because for
the first three months i traveled
everywhere i met six seven thousand
people personally
at least i made presentation of the
strategy to everybody because i wanted
especially for the talents to remain in
the company so i needed to
show myself personally and to tell
people that i was confident on the
change and they they needed to know
me as well to understand i was not crazy
as well because that was a kind of a
possibility by the way that is exactly
what i preach
and i went through something very
similar when kovet hit
we had to pivot and the old way is
where we made most of our income from
live events i mean i could tell you what
the numbers
look like they were pretty steep down
and so
i gave the exact same speech which is
i have a vision i'm very confident in
this vision
this is not up for discussion or debate
this is not a democracy i
didn't necessarily say it in those terms
but at the end of the day
i had to rely on the team i knew i had
the vision but i couldn't implement it
by myself
and so just like you did you went around
and you built
the confidence in you and your vision
that they would support and they would
help
i think what a lot of ceos mistake which
is having vision
and telling people how to do it are two
different things
which is you said i have this vision and
this is where we're going okay
how are we going to get there you asked
for buy-in and you asked for support
you stayed focused on where you were
going in the future
as opposed to dictating i would need you
to do
this specific thing you have no
creativity you have no bandwidth you
have nothing to contribute
absolutely exactly so and following what
you're saying
you did that in the period of crisis as
i did
so it's exactly the same so because you
are forced to do something that is
different you have no choice no choice
and
the vision is to be extremely clear but
then the people need to
to be completely empowered completely
empowered to make it so they need to
have the autonomy to express their
creativity at the marks
how did you get like this how did you
become vision focused people focused
you know what what where did you grow up
you grew up i know you grew up in italy
but where where did you grow up in italy
i grew up in the same house where i
still live in uh close to rajamilia with
my family i mean i was born in this same
house where i stay now
and with my kids and my wife so and i
kept this
these rules i mean i always decided not
to move the family despite the fact that
i lived like
five years in paris five years in london
one year in
sydney so i was commuting when i was
there from monday to friday was
traveling everywhere and then back
always back friday night and they're
staying on the weekend so
this idea of not changing despite the
success
trying not to change your personality
because what i hate in people that they
they become successful or famous or rach
or whatever
that they change their behavior they all
friends are not any more old friends
and they lose completely the reason why
they became successful but the reason
they became successful because they had
this kind of you know ground
and they need to keep that and and this
is that are the value that matters
all the rest is just superficiality i
don't want my kids to grow in that
direction
so that's the reason why i wanted them
to stay there get a little bit of
what i was able to learn from my parents
and what did you learn from parents
were you closer with your mother or your
father i was close with both of them and
my mom
i lost my my my mother quite early but
she was 55 when she died
but i mean both of them had different
characteristics my mother was like
someone helping everybody i remember
when
when a new business started in this
small town rubiere she
was always going there like easy to buy
a newspaper or to buy a
i mean meat or whatever with every new
business that was
happening she was going there in order
to help the business
amazing i remember when she died we went
to the to the church i mean the church
was
full of people i mean the people many
people didn't even know and
she did everything without telling
anybody helping people
so that of course shared me a lot in
terms of values in terms of you know
giving back
and and trying to you know to remain
as i was and and my father was a
on the same very good character
different in terms of
uh characteristic and more you know
business treated etc so i think i i
took a little bit of both of them you
learned the business from your dad and
the the humanity from your mother yeah
yeah
probably i mean i was lucky because i
mean despite the fact that
my parents didn't go to school none of
them
because i mean at that time in italy i
mean it was not as easy to go to school
so they didn't
they went to the elementary school both
of them for for three years
i was lucky because i mean as soon as i
started the school i was always the best
so i was i mean i had this kind of
possibility to to to learn very very
fast
you know i the chance to build on that
because it was for me was very easy to
learn things and then to
your brothers and sisters your brothers
and sisters only child only child
very
[Laughter]
can you give me an example something
that you did in your career it didn't
have to be a commercial success
that you loved being a part of and that
if everything you did in your career
from this point on was like that if you
could do that again
you'd be the happiest person alive there
was a kind of a turning point
if i think about my my career i mean i
was not
born extremely talented i was very very
shy from the beginning very very
shy but there was a moment that really
shaped the future of my career i think
that
at the beginning of my career i i
started i started working for 10 years i
was in accenture
i didn't speak in very much english at
that time i mean i learned english in
italy
from you know school so i learned
grammar but i never spoke
so i joined this international company
um in bologna and the company ed stiles
i think a kind of a university in
chicago
close to chicago saint charles and at
certain point after four years i asked
my
manager say look i would like to improve
my english
send me to census to spend like a week
and do a kind of a marketing course
whatever it's going to be
so i went there and i really started
the week and i didn't understand one
single word
of the guy speaking and you know you
america
they treated me like the the monkey of
the of the bunch so they didn't give me
the information because nobody wanted
you on their team
[Laughter]
so the last day the very last day i
finally
understand a little bit of the
conversation
so i went to the bathroom and at the
same time
the teacher came came to the bathroom as
well we were we extended together
imagine what we were doing
and i i told the teacher you know what
today i understood 80 percent of what
you said
and what you asked he answered to me was
you know what the most important thing
we are in the
remaining twenty percent
[Laughter]
so i went back to italy and i started
because i was moving from my little town
to bologna every day by car
so 50 minutes drive going back and forth
i bought audiobooks possible in english
i started listening all
everything that was possible watching
movies after one year i went to attend
the same
course the same teacher i mean my
english was amazing
and the at the end of the seven days the
guy the same teacher
stood up in front of all the owners
saying you know what i was so impressed
because in one year i met someone that
didn't speak a word and now he's able to
teach to all of you americans
how to put together a centers and that
to me gave me
the point that you can really do
whatever you you want
if you put a hard work behind it
it's not just about talent of course
talent is important but 90 percent
is about hard work and and being there
and being constant
then you can overcome all the
difficulties all the
missing things that you have in because
you were born in a situation was not
ideal
by the way so that i apply all of that
in everything that of course helps you
as well to to feel better because i mean
you
you feel a lot of holes in your
personality you mean your confidence
grows
my confidence grows exactly the
confidence grows the law and then that's
the reason why
i was able to take that risk in gucci
because i had all this experience before
me in times of career in terms of person
in terms of family so i was not
nervous at all about the the change
because at the very end
first of all and what i said at the very
very beginning the very first day when i
joined gucci the very first meeting
i was supposed to give a speech to all
the communication teams of gucci
so i started to meet like 25 people 30
people there were 500 people
waiting for me for the speech the
climate was a disaster i mean it was
this kind of fear because they were used
to have
presentation of five hours more or less
about numbers
about kpis and now it's not about the
motion or the rest
so at certain point i started my speech
and i was watching the faces i will go
oh sad
you say you know what please
stand smiley because i mean remember you
are privileged
you work in fashion in one of the best
most interesting industries in the world
creativity can blossom but we are not
saving lives
so we can improve lives but we're not
saying that we're not inventing medicine
we're not in a penicillin
so relax take it easy keep it
take a big breath and then start smiling
because i mean i don't want to have
these faces in front of me
but by the way that little dose of
reality there's only a few industries
that are really essential and important
as you said
medicines or the cure for cancer that
stuff is
important stuff yeah exactly and as you
said you can
improve lives but you're not saving
lives no by any stretch of the imagine
and i think sometimes people in business
treat their employees
as if this is cancer yeah exactly and
the kpis become
like if we don't hit this someone's
going to die exactly yeah
it's like a war and and listen if you
talk to many people in the fashion
industry
if i tell them we are not saving live
center no no i mean fashion
i mean we change the attitude we change
the behavior which
yeah you help people to feel more
confident because they dress better of
course
but relax i mean we have been without
fashion for like uh
thousands of years and the people that
will keep on being maybe even happier
than now so
i mean let's put everything in
perspective this is such a great little
insight so i'll give you an example so i
um i had the opportunity to eat at 11
madison park
which used to be the best restaurant in
the world in new york city
and everybody's so nice and happy and
all the servers are just lovely and it's
not stuffy
i asked the server i said i'm looking
around everybody's smiling
i said do you ever get customers that
are not nice
he said occasionally he says usually
it's when their assistant book them
some restaurant and they don't know
where they're going or they show up and
they don't realize that it's a chef's
tasting menu and they're upset that they
didn't get to choose their own food
then they're a little grumpy i said well
what do you do in those circumstances he
said we may just make them whatever they
want we just make them food
and then he says he sort of paused for a
second he goes it's just food who cares
[Laughter]
right and like this is one of the best
restaurants in the world
and they're just like eh it's food like
we take pride in it
we believe in it we chose a career in
this but the reality is
it's food and by the way between gucci
and eleven madison park these are two of
the
the best brands the best quality in the
world
and yet both don't take themselves too
seriously
i love that it's true
tell me an early specific childhood
memory
an early specific happy childhood memory
something that really stands
out to you my child was being very happy
i mean
i don't know i mean it was a poor family
the one that came up from my mind as
soon as you asked me when i was living
in this
house i had a friend that was close to
me
we didn't have television we didn't do
the eating system
anything so of course we were always
outside to play football or to to try to
make any kind of you know silly you know
games once we discovered a bunch of eggs
i mean many many eggs mean fresh eggs
and sometimes we went to the cinema
during the theater during the
or sunday we said why we don't do the
theater in
in our house so we started to throw the
eggs
in the house in a inside the house to to
make it like a movie
like the screen so you're throwing eggs
against the wall to make a movie screen
to make a movie screen exactly we were
four years old three years four years
old
and then my grandmother that
she was following me because i mean my
parents were working
she realized that at the end of the
crash so we know like one other day
where completely crashed
in front of the of the wall so we
started we started you know
running away and we close my grandmother
inside the house
and we we take out the key so i don't
know why i remember that
i think it's the first time that they
say this kind of story in my entire life
but i mean
when you ask me there is a moment we
were laughing like crazy because
we had two little kids yeah we thought
that was very funny
do you have a sense of what is it about
that story because you did lots of funny
things that that were fun when you were
kids do you have a sense of what it is
about that story that really
that you still think about it that you
that you that you still remember it
i think it's about the fact that i mean
you know i think that despite the fact
you don't have anything you can have fun
a lot with little things you don't need
to have a lot of money to do it i mean
at the end how much money do you need to
have in your life and at the very end
you're gonna eat three times a day
like everybody else so i mean you need
to put everything in perspective so you
can really have fun and
i remember the love with my friends we
were laughing like crazy
i mean if you think about it at the end
what do you really need
to be happy simplicity and basic things
are the most important
you have to appreciate the irony that
you come from these humble roots
you have this intense humility this
belief in the simple things
and you work at the highest levels of
luxury
it's kind of funny you have to admit
like you didn't work for some
mass-market brand and yet you bring this
intense sense of
groundedness and humility and and
gratitude
i i just find it so interesting thank
you
and if you look at what gucci has done
you know from the stodgy old-fashioned
museum brand the the best way to
describe what you have brought to this
company is fun
what's so fascinating is what the
humility translates you can work at the
highest levels
but what you're bringing is joy and fun
and don't take life too seriously
this is the value of humility it's
actually translatable everywhere
and the gratitude you have from where
you came from i love the fact that you
still
are in your home that you grew up in
that you still commute
from this little town in italy and i
guess it's a reminder right you don't
want to forget you fear that if you left
absolutely you would become jaded and
you would you would forget your roots
yeah absolutely every weekend when i go
back i mean i feel i mean i
go back to talk to my you know friends
that they were doing
schools with me in the same same time
with completely different careers
completely different in the background
etc but i mean
we keep on talking about the stupid
thing that we were doing when we were
kids and playing football and all the
rest and i feel at home and i feel
relaxed i mean all the
adrenaline goes down so it's perfect so
good
so nice to talk to you so nice to see
you i'm such a fan
i really am really really i'm really
happy to hear that from you i'm really
happy
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and if you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other
you